So now that Pokemon Go has penetrated the
barrier between fiction and reality, its rich
mythology is making its way into the real
world.
But some of these stories are even stranger
than fiction.
The app's popularity has opened up a wellspring
of misinformation about events surrounding
the hunt for augmented reality pocket monsters.
Here are a few of the more bizarre hoaxes
and why they're absolutely not true—and
why some actually are.
Sibling stabbing
No, a Florida kid named Timmy did not stab
his younger brother to death after a misunderstanding
about deleted Pokemon.
While the unchecked story spread like chlamydia
on social media sites, many readers failed
to realize that the fake story originated
from Cartel Press, a website which specializes
in intentionally fake news.
While many of their headlines are obviously
satirical, such as "Zoo claims gorilla had
ties to ISIS," the story of young, murderous
Timmy offered no humor in its retelling.
Even if you ignore the completely fake nature
of the site, there are absolutely no incidents
reported in Jacksonville similar to this event.
Additionally, you don't even really delete
your Pokemon; you just trade them in for delicious
candies.
Get with it, noob.
You'll begin to notice that Cartel Press is
a trend here.
"You will never find a more wretched hive
of scum and villainy."
The $500 million lawsuit
Another story that traces back to Cartel Press
is the tale of Charley, who wandered into
the street while playing Pokemon Go, was hit
by a car, and is now suing app makers Niantic
for $500 million.
While the post's language is much more obviously
a parody of the frivolous litigation trend,
readers were once again fooled.
To date, Niantic has not been the subject
of any Pokemon Go-related injury lawsuits.
However, Niantic’s previous GPS-based game,
Ingress, is related to at least two reported
deaths.
A gamer in Dublin fell off a pier in 2016
while playing the game.
Another player wandered into traffic and was
hit by a bus in Rio de Janeiro in 2014.
Vice interviewed Cartel Press owner Pablo
Reyes, whose only reasoning for spreading
paranoia was this:
"People always expect something anyways so
if you write about it beforehand it's like
you predicted it."
Psychic-type Pokemon, look out.
You've got some competition.
Bad Neighborhood
Because the bogus news from the Onion-wannabe
never ends, we can also confirm that "Marcus
Jackson" did not get stabbed during his Pokemon
adventures because he, and we quote,
"...didn't realize he had stepped into what
is know [sic] as a bad neighborhood."
Also from Cartel Press, and therefore inherently
false: the rumor of the highway Pikachu hundred-car
pileup, and ISIS taking credit for Pokemon
Go's login issues.
True, however, is the remarkably similar story
of Michael Baker, who was stabbed while playing
in Forest Grove, Oregon.
The player initially refused treatment for
his injuries so that he could continue playing,
but later sought medical attention, according
to an interview with KATU 2 News.
"I'm just gonna keep catchin' 'em all ya know?
That's, that's pretty much what's gonna happen."
No Trespassing
Another fake news site reported that a kid
named "Arthur Disby" was shot when he entered
the house of an aging widow in order to catch
a wild Pokemon.
While The National Report is another veiled
satire site, many readers believed that the
story was completely real, based on comments
left on the page.
There have been no confirmed reports of breaking
and entering in order to catch imaginary monsters,
primarily due to the fact that you simply
don't need to be that close to a Pokemon to
be able to capture it.
Based on the game's geolocation, you can usually
catch any Pokemon that happens to pop up within
the borders of a building without actually
entering it.
And now you know.
Simpsons did it
While The Simpsons has predicted plenty of
things, internet hoaxes often give the show
more credit than it deserves.
Despite popular opinion, the show did not
predict Donald Trump's campaign announcement,
nor did it anticipate the creation of Pokemon
Go.
In a currently popular meme, a four-fingered,
yellow hand points at an empty corner while
a smartphone in the other hand displays a
Pikachu.
Efforts have been made to make this truly
look like an older screencap from the show,
but it's all Photoshop, folks.
You can see the original clip in the episode
"How I Spent My Strummer Vacation."
"But he's just like you or me or Jesus over
there!"
The inevitable fee
If you want to send someone into a panic,
tell them that they have to pay for a once-free
service.
Like the hundreds of "Facebook fee" scares
that preceded them, the Pokemon Go fee rumors
are false.
Seeing an opportunity to ride the wave of
the game, scammers began sending out emails
claiming that Pokemon Go would soon cost $12.99
per month to play, mostly so Niantic could
beef up their straining servers.
And apparently augment the fortune already
being spent in the app's shop.
Niantic has not announced a fee, nor do they
have any plans to, which has been confirmed
by The Verge.
Scammers, however, have been using these fake
announcements to collect users' personal information.
Don't fall for it.
Land Down Under
And no, Australian police are not targeting
Pokemon Go players, despite a popular image
that's been circulating online.
While the image does come from a real sign
in Australia, it's also been the subject of
countless manipulations over the years.
There's no reason for police officers to target
users of an app about imaginary animal poaching.
They almost definitely have bigger problems
to worry about.
"That's not a knife.
That's a knife."
The Murder Witness
According to initial accounts, an Uber driver
named Alex Ramirez was streaming his Pokemon
Go adventures between stops and witnessed
a body being tossed out of a car.
"Oh my god. Oh my god! Holy s***! Oh god!
This guy just killed this chick, oh f***!
Holy s***! This guy just killed, oh my god,
oh my god I just witnessed a f****** murder!"
He subsequently called 911, gave the location
of the body, and reported being followed by
the murderers…all before getting fired by
Uber. The video was convincing enough that
a few top YouTube hoax debunkers fell for
it, but none actually bothered to verify their
sources.
Gizmodo reports that calls to the local police
revealed that there were no bodies found,
nor any murders matching that description.
Calls to Uber also revealed that they hadn't
fired anyone over a Pokemon incident, only
temporarily suspended a driver after rider
complaints. This was because Ramirez was playing
while driving at high speeds, which is obvious
on his channel. GoFundMe quickly pulled the
page set up to help Ramirez, since it was
put up under false pretenses, and the whole
thing was revealed to be a huge publicity
stunt. And possibly a serious case of fraud.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which Pokemon Go hoaxes you fell for…